この単語をより自然に聞こえるようにするための 3 つのヒント
は、日本語の
ラの音を
言うときに、音の最初
で唇を丸めたり、突き出したりしない
ことです。 自然な方法
ですが、あなたは私の唇が
かなり丸みを帯びて
再び
突き出ているのを見る
ことができ
ます。 だから私が
ちょうど最初だけこの音を言うなら
、私の唇は本質的にニュートラルだと言うので
、それがヒント1です。
日本語で唇を丸めないでください。ヒント2は
、この単語
はもっとまたは 単語
の真ん中にアクセントがないので、そうではありませんが、英語を
母国語とする人なら多かれ少なかれフラットです。
アクセントを真ん中に置きたい傾向があります
が、 アクセントはありませ
ん t はロボットが好きな
ので、それが 2 番目のヒントです。次に
3 番目のヒントは、英語のネイティブ スピーカーである場合、たとえ
この言葉を多かれ少なかれフラットな方法で言ったとしても、言い
たくない傾向があるということです。
最初の母音を明確に発音
してください この単語の最初
の母音は正しくあり
ません 英語のネイティブ スピーカーであれば、
おそらく無意識のうちに uh uh と言いたくなるでしょう
この単語の最初の母音は正しくありません
非常に典型的な非常に不自然な
外国人のやり方では、私は言うことができます
watashi
watashi もう一度最初の母音はああではないことに注意してください。
しかし、それは
uh watashi です。
これは、母音の削減として知られている
ものです。
英語と同じように日本語でも発生するので
、それを認識して、
最初の母音も明確に表現してみてください。
これは、w が削除
されたこの単語のより口語的な形にも当てはまります。
アルトグ
もし私がそれを言っているのに、
私がそれを説明した後、あなたは
おそらく誰もそのように言うことはないだろうと思うでしょう
が
、あなたが意識していなければ、これは実際にはかなり一般的です.
最初の母音を明確に表現したい
場合は
、一部の女性スピーカーがそうするように w を落としているかどうかに関係なく
、ここでも 3 つのヒントは、1 つは
唇を丸めたり、
日本語で突き出さないことです w 2 は w を言わないでください
真ん中にアクセントのある単語、それから3つ
が最初の母音を明確に表現して
います。
大丈夫ではありません。知らない人に役立つことを願って
います。以下にリンクされているパトレオンで日本語の発音と高低アクセントを教えてい
ます。将来の日本語研究と幸運を祈っています。 また会いましょう